[Music]
while I'm watching this live I'm like
this cannot be happening this cannot be
happening I think it just blew all of
our minds that we would see someone that
looked like my cousin Dominique on an
NBA court it's the most impossible thing
I think I've ever witnessed in my life
[Applause]
when most Americans think about Asians
they think about dry cleaners they think
about I.T guy small passive diminutive
unathletic the stereotyping the derision
are so rampant you don't think no Asian
kid is this size is going to be dunking
this is who I am this is what I'm
capable of all you guys need to do is
watch and see
this kid came out of nowhere started
balling like for real it wasn't just
Asian people talking about it everybody
was talking about it the Lakers came in
with the idea that we're gonna end this
fairy tale we're gonna end it tonight
but Jeremy just kept making shots he
gave all y'all according to see is this
the other plot of Space Jam like whose
superpowers did Jeremy win steal yo this
dude scored 38 points at the Garden at
the mecca the biggest thing that Sammy
brought was hope it inspired people
the last few years Asian Americans have
just gotten beaten down
and when I think back on Lynn sanity I
long to feel those moments of just pure
joy and unity this moment it broke the
Matrix for us